action is former US Attorney for the
District of Columbia Joe digenova
also the author of a brand-new book
comes out I believe next week of the
week after Jesus is risen
Paul in the early church is how I'm
sorry October the second available
pre-order on amazon.com
barnesandnoble.com and tomorrow Hannity
calm our friend David Limbaugh by the
way both have done legal work for me
because I'm in such legal trouble just
about every other day of my life it
seems like I have every lawyer but and
I've had dinner with both of them let's
start with you Joe and these
developments and I also want you to
focus in a little bit on we do know a
grand jury is impaneled we don't know
what's going on there we don't know
whether in the unredacted pages 10 to 12
17 to 34 we don't know what's in the
302s everybody that I know that knows
something or says they do say it's
blockbuster well here's what we do know
we do know from the text revealed by
struck and page yesterday that we now
are at a different place the walls are
closing in but they're not closing in on
the president they're closing in on the
FBI and the Department of Justice under
President Obama those text messages by
struck and page which reveal an illegal
media strategy to ill legally and
criminally release FISA warrant
information and named a US citizen who
information they gave to the New York
Times is a criminal offense and by
mentioning Carter page they have now
created massive civil liability for
everybody involved in revealing Carter
pages name including themselves James
Baker the former FBI general counsel
price step everybody in the chain of
command in addition the reporters for
the New York Times have no privileges
now they also can be sued by Carter page
because although they may have been
legally able to accept information by
publishing it they revealed classified
information
that smeared Carter page mr. Pope out is
going to be a very wealthy man I kind of
agree with you actually buy it by the
end of all this with the Medicaid we
know that the grand jury has been seated
we know that they're looking at the
lying issues involving McCabe and ice
correct
I have different sources that are
telling me also they're looking into the
FISA abuse issues they aren't if they
are the problem is we don't know whether
it's Hueber or the National Security
Division at the Justice Department the
best information is that it is the
National Security Division at the
Justice Department what are they looking
at what wouldn't that mean everybody
that signed off on those FISA warrants
in other words that committed fraud on
the FISA courts that would Mitton
information perfectly yes yes yes and
that is why and I I mentioned this the
other night if you go back and look at
rod Rhodes and Stein's testimony he
answered a question in a very strange
way he said I am relieved that I have
been relieved of responsibilities
involving that area that is FISA the
reason he has been relieved of those
duties is that there is a criminal
investigation as you just mentioned
involving McCabe and struck and Baker
and nobody knows who is ultimately
responsible for all of this
what about homey oh there's no doubt
know they're all involved there they're
going down you know I know and people
don't like to hear this James Comey
struck McCabe they're all going down on
the FISA warrant stuff that's just not
even an open quiet anymore let me get to
David Limbaugh David I never thought in
my life that and with these everything
that we've been breaking these these new
texts are a disaster I mean you
literally have all this criminality
fixing an investigation using Russia
information disseminating lies before
and after the election top DOJ FBI
intelligence agencies CIA
all to help elect one candidate over
another you know literally propagating
false Russian information feeding it
trying to feed it and funnel it through
Bruce or into Muller's office I can't
believe this has happened
with some of the the people and agencies
and institutions that I personally grown
up having the most respect for in my
life yeah
yes is it any coincidence that Comey
himself leaked on purpose to start a
Special Counsel investigation and now we
have two of its top lieutenants who were
leaking who are deliberately leaking in
a deliberate media leak strategy it is
they were flourishing in a Comey leaked
culture and can you imagine how
ludicrous this is that the FBI was
investigating these people in the
supposedly in the periphery of the Trump
campaign for alleged collusion with
Russia to interfere with our election
when they themselves were interfering
with our election all right Joe I heard
a little sinister laugh from Joe to
Jennifer when you mentioned call me why
is that Joe he's going down the dirty
cop is gonna go down
you haven't been wrong yet all right
thank you both